[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARTHUR BROOKS: Once you do the
work of learning about happiness,
that's when it really gets
interesting, because the second part--
the second stage is
applying it to your life.
You've got to understand it, but
then you've got to practice it.
Everything is about practice.
Look, you can read a book about
golf, but you can't play golf
unless you get out there and play.
And the same thing is true of happiness.
You're going to learn a whole lot
about happiness in this class,
but then you got to practice it.
And we'll give you
the exercises that you
need so that you can do the practice.
And then the beautiful part comes in,
because you'll be ready to teach it.
Then you'll be able to
help others become happier.
And when you do that, then it's
locked in forever in your life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]